[Musique]
[Rires]
ma femme a quand même récupéré à
l'instant je la vois arriver garée juste
là juste là et je la connais tellement
je vous le dis elles vont faire le coup
de la porte bloquée et et va continuer à
avancer ça pour elle c'est le délire je
la connais tellement c'est le seul coup
qu'on peut faire pour me faire chier
regarde ça on va arriver
voilà
chez les u télépathique où il fait froid
maintenant il a rien à lui mais est ce
que tu veux te perds sont
alors je vais disposer ce biais sur la
bouteille
et toi avec juste un seul doigt tu vas
devoir réussir à faire tomber le billet
mais sans faire tomber le bouchon
city arrive pas je te montre accord mais
alors tant que tu viennes pas le biais
de ses news
auplata est dommage que
c'est toi qui as
oui non si je veuille ou non si je
reviens aussi je ferai du mois six jours
à nouveau s'ils jouent une girafe donc
je ne j'ai une gueule le géant du web
[Musique]
on
je vous parle d'un temps que les moins
de vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
mon marque en ces temps là accroché ces
dix là jusque sous nos fenêtres et
syllables garni qui nous servait denis
ne payez pas dominant c'est là qu'on
s'est connu moi qui criait famine et toi
toi tu poser nu
nos best christmas gift
ouest